the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I actually want to talk
about a few different things in the
video a few days ago Entertainment
Weekly posted some information about the
final season of Game of Thrones I
haven't really had the chance to discuss
any of it yet but almost all the
information was already known by most of
us that stay up to date with the show
during the off season the main reason
why I wanted to talk about this is
because it did actually confirm
something significant about the big
battle against the night king which is
something we have all been waiting for I
also want to play a few video clips from
some of the earlier seasons of the show
because I think it could be
foreshadowing what could happen during
the battle in the north
ever since everyone saw the pilot
episode of Game of Thrones we have all
been waiting for the day that the White
Walkers and the whites made it south of
the wall now that day has finally come
and so far it has not disappointed
because not only do they have a leader
in the night king but they also have
Giants bears a dragon and who knows what
else at the end of the season 7 finale
we finally saw the night king bring down
the wall and begin to move his army
south into Westeros ever since that
episode ended I think most of us have
been wondering where would the big
battle take place well thanks to the
press release from Entertainment Weekly
we now have a pretty good answer
along with the first official photo of
season 8 the photo really doesn't reveal
any new information in fact it looks
like they're wearing the same outfits
from season 7 although they do have a
few minor adjustments but now I want to
get into some of the good stuff as you
all know Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
are currently on their way to Winterfell
to prepare for their fight against the
night king but little do they know the
night king is already on his way south
the night king was able to bring down
the wall at eastwatch-by-the-sea and now
he's heading south with his dragon
giants White Walkers and nearly 100,000
White's
according to Daenerys Targaryen the
night king is advancing south while Jon
and Daenerys are heading north these two
parties are on a collision
course that will end in death and
destruction at the starks castle in
Winterfell now the reason why I wanted
to discuss this today is for two
different reasons
one of the reasons is because of the
most recent press release that was
posted online by Entertainment Weekly I
would not really consider any of this to
be spoilers because HBO did give them
the green light to publish the
information not to mention most of us
already knew this anyway because I have
reported on nearly all of this in
previous videos already but according to
Entertainment Weekly the opening scene
of season 8 will take place in
Winterfell what's interesting about this
release is it actually goes into detail
about some of the renovations they've
made to the castle and in my opinion I
think they done this for one reason in
particular I'm sure most of you can
imagine after I read the article I got
very excited because it did fall in line
with many of my own beliefs about the
final season which I have shared on this
channel quite a few times the main
battle with the night king will take
place at Winterfell which I did say for
over a year now but I think the article
helps back it up even more so let's take
a quick look at what it says last April
crew member revealed that Game of
Thrones had wrapped 55 night shoots
while filming a battle media outlets
around the world ran story saying the
final seasons battle took twice as long
as the 25 days shoot for season six is
climactic Battle of the Basterds this
wildly understated what really happened
the 55 nights were only for the battles
outdoor scenes at the Winterfell set
filming then moved into the studio where
supports need continued shooting the
same battle for weeks after that it's
berdal Dinklage says it makes the Battle
of the bastards look like a theme park
the battle doesn't just have one focus
either but rather intercuts between
multiple characters involved in their
own survival storylines that feel like
its own genre having the largest battle
doesn't sound very exciting it actually
sounds pretty boring Benioff says part
of our challenge and really Miguel's
challenge is how to keep that compelling
we've been building towards this since
the very beginning it's the living
against the dead and you can't do that
in a 12-minute sequence to help pull it
off the production hugely expand that
it's set for the stark ancestral home of
Winterfell adding a towering castle
exterior a larger courtyard
and more interconnected rooms and
ramparts strolling around the new
Winterfell was like wandering a
sprawling immersive medieval resort
compared with its previous days in like
scale the ground is covered with snow
and blood the air is thick with smoke
from the fire pits you can turn any
direction and only see more Winterfell
it's easy to feel like you somehow
wandered into Westeros so as you can see
it is now confirmed the biggest battle
in Game of Thrones history what I mean
to say is the biggest battle in
television history will take place in
Winterfell which makes perfect sense
because this is where it all started and
this is where it will end
obviously Winterfell will come under
attack by a force unlike anything we've
ever seen
the Starks family home will erupt into
chaos as the night king and his army try
to overrun the ancient castle
what makes this battle even more
interesting is because of the Starks
connection with the night king in my
opinion Winterfell isn't just the home
of Jon Snow and the other stark children
but at one time it was also the home of
the night king because I do believe he
was a stark he was actually one of the
very first Starks who most likely
assisted in securing this location for
the castle this isn't just a battle of
the living versus of the dead but it's
also a battle for who is truly the king
in the north and the rightful heir of
Winterfell but who will come out on top
Jon Snow or the night king one of these
characters will not make it out of this
battle alive you don't film a battle
that's twice the size of the Battle of
the bastards for it not to have an epic
conclusion at the end of that episode
they made Winterfell nearly twice as big
as it previously was because the battle
was taken place in that location so I
highly doubt they will have the battle
and anywhere else now the other reason
why I wanted to talk about this is
because of some potential foreshadowing
from some of the earlier seasons if
you've been keeping up to date with all
the spoilers then you would already know
some of the things that would happen at
Winterfell some photos came out that
showed dead bodies littered all around
the property and we've even seen a video
of the Castle on fire so how many of you
actually think some of the characters
will have to flee from the scene
obviously if the castle comes under
heavy attack to the point that it looks
like the living can lose
some of the characters that aren't able
to fight will need to get the hell out
of there
but how like I said in the earlier
seasons we heard about Winterfell secret
tunnels but we have yet to see them if
there would come a time that any of the
Starks would need to use these then
perhaps we could see it happen next
season during the biggest battle in Game
of Thrones history the first time we
heard about Winterfell secret tunnels
was when Theon Greyjoy had controlled
the castle as we all know the castle
ends up getting surrounded by Ramsay and
his men which leaves Theon trapped
inside but maester Luwin tells Theon
that he has other options take a listen
to what he says once a man has taken the
black he's beyond reach of the roar all
his past crimes are forgiven we'll make
it to the wall I won't make it 10 feet
past the Winterfell gates there are ways
hidden passageways built so the Lords of
Winterfell could escape maester Luwin
told Theon there was a way for him to
escape without getting noticed even
though we have never seen the secret
tunnels I think they could become very
useful next season when the castle comes
under attack they already told us they
made some major renovations to the
Winterfell said so I don't think it's
too crazy to think they could have added
some tunnels for the people to escape if
need be now I know some of you may be
thinking just because we heard about it
one time doesn't mean we're ever gonna
see it but if you have a good memory
then you would know this isn't the only
time the tunnels were ever mentioned
during a conversation with Melisandre
and Jon Snow back in season 5 we heard
about this again take a listen to what
Melisandre says during the scene
Lord Commander how can I help you come
with us when we ride south none of us
knew the castle as well as you do it's
hidden tunnels its weaknesses its people
Winterfell was your home once don't you
want to chase the rats out of it as you
can see Melisandre talks about
Winterfell having secret passages as
well but is it just a coincidence I
imagine there will be a lot of
characters
that aren't exactly prepared to fight
the dead I don't think we will see
characters like Sansa missandei or even
the maester pick up a sword so if they
have tunnels under Winterfell this would
be the perfect opportunity for us to
finally see them get put to good use
depending on how the battle turns out we
could see all of the main characters go
into the tunnels if they aren't flying
on any of the Dragons but when you
consider the fact that they spent over
fifty five nights filming the battle at
Winterfell
I really can't imagine any of our
favorite characters turning and running
away the knight King must be stopped as
soon as possible and I happen to think
the night king falls right here where
winter has fell before I've said it a
dozen times but I'll say it again just
in case this is the first time you're
watching one of my videos in my opinion
Winterfell will not fall but the night
king will the Winterfell Castle has been
here for thousands of years and it will
remain here even after the show ends
this was also foreshadowed during the
same scene with the on Greyjoy first
time I saw Winterfell look like
something that had been here for
thousands of years and would be here for
thousands of years after I was dead it
doesn't really matter how big the night
king and his army is he's not gonna be
able to take the castle because as long
as a stark remains in Winterfell they
will stop the night King from making it
any further south than this I happen to
think that motto dates all the way back
to the first long night when winter fell
upon Westeros the same thing goes for
house Starks ancestral Valyrian steel
sword ice there is a very good reason
why their sword had that name and you
can all guess what that is it has a
deep-rooted history what the White
Walkers just like everything else that
has to do with the Starks it has to be a
member from this house that stops the
knight King from advancing any further
that's why everything about that house
dates back to the Age of Heroes when the
White Walkers came for the first time
think about it like this House Stark was
founded directly after the long night
ended as soon as the White Walkers fled
back to the far north the wall was
constructed then Winterfell was built
they knew it was only a matter of time
before they came again that's one of the
reasons why the wall was put
in the first place but they needed
something else what happens if the White
Walkers make it past the wall we need to
build something else very close just in
case they do knock it down so what do
they do next
they build Winterfell and the Starks are
now in charge of protecting the north
and what do they make their house words
winter is coming because they knew one
day they would return so what do they
always make sure to say to every member
of the house a stark must always remain
in Winterfell because when this day
comes you will need to be the one to
stop them after the wall falls we are
the first line of defense ok so now that
we do all that how do we stop them
obviously House Stark would need a very
special weapon to do this because
regular weapons do not work this is when
the origin of House Stark since estriol
sword begins that sword is called ice
and that name dates all the way back to
the Age of Heroes even though they're
current sword was only 500 years old it
was the actual name of the sword that
symbolized what was needed to defeat
them a special weapon that is carried by
someone in House Stark but the only
problem is everyone forgot about all
this overtime after thousands of years
started to pass without any signs of the
White Walkers the Stark started to get
too comfortable and they forgot winter
is coming no longer had the same meaning
they always said a stark must always
remain in Winterfell but they never
really knew why but this is something
brain stark can see in a vision next
season the North remembers after all in
the weirwood trees remember to brain can
actually go back and see the true
purpose of his entire house and
everything about them it's not a
coincidence that brain stark and Jon
Snow are the closest connected
characters to the night king this is
their destiny and it was all set in
motion the day House Stark was founded
this goes deep Winterfell also has
its own magic built into the castle not
only because of the weirwood tree in the
godswood but because of the castle was
also constructed with the help of the
children of the forest now we are told
Winterfell was built by Brandon the
Builder with the help of the Giants but
we are also told they were the ones who
built the wall with the help of the
children of the forest they had woven
their magic spells into its foundation
and on
betting they did something very similar
to Winterfell I think this all connects
to the reason why a stark must always
remain in Winterfell because one day
winter would come and they would need to
be right in position to stop it from
laying its darkness all over Westeros
it's not a coincidence that old man told
brain stark the story about the White
Walkers coming when he was in this very
castle that wasn't just some bedtime
story that was actually preparing bran
stark and us as the audience because it
would eventually happen one day and bran
stark needed to be here when that day
comes he did go on his journey beyond
the wall and he found out what winter is
coming truly meant but now he has made
it home for his final act fortunately
for the Starks all of the remaining
members of the House are now in the same
location and it couldn't have happened
at a better time
we know the night King is on his way but
he will not be able to defeat all the
Starks when they are in the north
together
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
the opening scene of the show began with
us getting our first glimpse of what
lied beyond the wall we were showing the
threat immediately and that's when the
countdown began we knew at that moment
there was something extremely dangerous
on the other side of that big-ass wall
and if they ever made it south it would
be a serious problem for the people of
Westeros but we were given the answer to
that problem in the very next scene
after they are introduced
we are shown Winterfell but why because
they are connected to each other but can
you guess which characters we see first
in Winterfell Jon Snow in bran stark
anyways I just wanted to go over some of
the information from the press release
because it did confirm the location of
the great war against the night king I
also wanted to let you know that I think
it makes perfect sense for the night
King to go to Winterfell let me know
what you think about the details leave
your questions or comments down below I
want to thank everyone for taking the
time out of your day to watch the video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank those of you who support the
channel on patreon thank you all very
much I hope you have a great day I'll
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]